if you were to instead add guacamole
every day to your diet you would be much
much better off so let's talk about it
so I just love avocados and especially
guacamole on my eggs on my burger on
other Foods put it on the salad I use
keto chips or keto crackers and that's
really the biggest problem with
guacamole is how do you consume it with
a chip that is you know it's not filled
with corn and corn oil and vegetable
oils that are highly inflammatory right
that's the problem with guacamole you're
at a restaurant and um what are you
going to eat it with a spoon well you
know people like those chips and then
they start feeling pain and inflammation
in their joints and so if you consumed
it with healthier foods you would be
actually in really good shape but
guacamole has some really good things in
it that I want to talk about and I will
put a really good recipe down below
exactly how to make it it's really
really simple so let's start with the
avocado why are they so healthy right
everyone keeps talking about this
monounsaturated fatty acid right it's
the same fat in olive oil and apparently
it's really good for insulin resistance
and supporting a healthy heart so
avocados have like 71 percent
monounsaturated fatty acids and olive
oil has roughly about the same but just
FYI lard is about 50 percent
monounsaturated talo which is beef fat
is about 50 percent
monounsaturated and butter has about 29
percent of it monounsaturated fatty
acids without getting too distracted I
just want to mention one thing about
saturated fats every single study that
I've seen that state that saturated fats
are bad for your heart etc etc
are not differentiating between the high
fat diet and the high carbohydrate diet
they all come with high carbohydrates so
how can anyone say that it's the fat
that's causing the damage and not the
high carb or even the combination of
both which creates glycation which is a
kind of The Binding of your fats with
your proteins creating a big problem
with your heart and your eyes and it
plugs everything up there is a very
huge study involving 135
000 Canadians okay and they looked at
the difference between what happens when
you eat a low carb versus a high fat
diet and which one of those is more
significant in relationship to mortality
and this is what they found it's the
lowering of the carbohydrates
not the lowering of fat will extend your
life I mean significant like 23 lower
risk of dying and also an 18 lowering
risk of getting a stroke which is pretty
significant but consuming avocados and
other fats on a healthy Keto Plan with
intermittent fasting it does several
things it helps make you more satisfied
it allows you to fast longer which will
then really get you into ketosis much
better because it's that frequent hunger
and frequent eating that really kind of
raises insulin so this is one of the big
reasons why you want to add fat to your
meal so you can fast longer and avocados
are a great way to do it avocados have a
lot of other things as well
phytonutrients they also have
glutathione which is a very powerful
antioxidant for your liver they have
carotenoids that help your vision and
also to prevent macular degeneration
avocados are good for inflammation and
your arteries in your brain and so
overall it's a very healthy food next
ingredient is lime or lemon okay I've
done a lot of videos on this first of
all if you actually have a lime or a
lemon and you just put that on it
instead of the juice you get a good
amount of vitamin C okay so that's one
thing number two you get citric acid
that can actually prevent kidney stones
if you're on the ketogenic plan that
could be a potential problem for some
people who are at risk but not if you
drink enough water like 2.5 liters per
day as well as having citrates citrates
bind with the oxalates and prevent those
stones also vitamin C is good to prevent
fat from accumulating in your liver it's
good for the liver in general and it's
also good for overall weight loss okay
we have avocados lime or lemon and then
sea salt right sea salt has like at
least 84 different minerals all the main
minerals plus a lot of trace minerals
that are hard to get in our foods and if
you're on the ketogenic plan you
definitely need more sea salt if you're
deficient in salt you'll feel weaker
okay that's one of the common symptoms
if you're concerned about too much
sodium there's a great type of salt that
is lower in sodium but higher in these
other minerals I'll put that link down
below and then we have the Tomato you
know there's a lot of different
varieties or types of tomato nowadays
unfortunately in the grocery store
they're just basically you know
tasteless but if you get a good tomato
and put in your guacamole it can really
help you with many different things and
one being lycopene lycopene is a
phytonutrient that's really good for the
heart it's an anti-inflammatory it's
good to protect your skin from
ultraviolet radiation it can act as a
sunscreen it also has anti-cancer
properties and is good for your bone and
then we get to the onion and if you can
get a red onion it's a little bit better
because it's going to be higher in this
main phytonutrient called quercetin
quercetin or Kirsten however you
pronounce it
is a very interesting compound
especially for allergies lowering
histamines but anything related to
allergies it's really good hay fever
things like that it's also good for
lowering blood pressure it's good for
gout it's really good for your immune
system and it can even decrease your
risk of certain types of cancer and if
you can't get red onions just do any
onions because all onions have this
compound but red tends to have more and
also onions are really high in vitamin C
this is why the used to way back when
they had a scurvy the sailors used to
consume onions to get their full vitamin
C complex onions also with this next
ingredient garlic really help your liver
complete this phase one phase two
detoxification right which is really
important in converting poisons to
harmless particles so they go from fat
soluble chemicals and toxins to
water-soluble chemicals the main
phytonutrient that a lot of people know
about is Allison and this compound does
a lot garlic is the heavy hitter with so
many things especially antimicrobial so
if you have you know parasites or too
much of the wrong unfriendly pathogens
in your body whether it's virus or
bacteria or a fungus or Yeast or mold or
candida boy garlic is what you need to
take garlic could be considered a
natural antibiotic but without the side
effects garlic also is great to act as a
natural blood thinner so it's really
good for the heart it's really good to
lower your blood pressure it's really
good to prevent cancer and it's also
good for your gut microbes it's also a
potent anti-inflammatory so if you can
just stick that in any different types
of foods that you're eating the more the
better and then we come to another
ingredient in guacamole called cilantro
cilantro has some really interesting
things as well specifically to protect
the liver again against heavy metals
okay so connect to bind with these heavy
metals and act as a natural chelator
which means to claw or to bind and to
pull out these heavy metals cilantro
also has been studied for seizures
because it has anti-convulsant
properties which is interesting so as
you can see guacamole is
a great heavy hitter of something that
can improve your health so if you were
to consume that every day on your Foods
uh this is what would happen number one
your blood sugars would be much better
because you would be able to fast longer
you would have an improved
cardiovascular system
you would have less pathogens in your
body you would have a stronger immune
system you would definitely have more
energy and less inflammation and all of
this on top of the benefits of being on
the healthy version of Keto and
intermittent fasting I think hands down
guacamole is something that you should
include on a regular basis so please
comment Down Below on your thoughts
about guacamole in general if you like
it and since I talked about putting
guacamole on a burger you should really
check out this video I did on one of the
healthiest foods which happens to be the
burger I put it up right here